everyone and welcome to the first video
ever I'm recording not from my usual
background from my apartment in Croatia
but rather from this very nice hotel
room in London in Heathrow and it will
serve as kind of a test that where
everything is set up correctly as I'm
using a new computer I knew everything
and not not really sure if I I it's been
some two years since the last time I've
created any interface and did everything
from scratch so it like I said it will
be a nice test for tomorrow as tomorrow
is the start of Game one of the 2018
World Chess Championship between Magnus
Carlsen Fabiano Caruana and also we will
as preparation we've already seen two
games from the 2012 double masters one
that Quora wanna won in round 1 then
Carlsen retaliated in round 6 as it was
a double round-robin but at the end of
the tournament they had the exact same
amount of points and they had to go into
tiebreaks this is one of the games from
the tiebreaks and since I had a really
tough days and you will realize there
was no video yesterday pretty tired from
the trip to London this will be somewhat
a short game but a very interesting one
and it will also give you a chance to
test your might solving the puzzle so
that being said let's check out this
very nice game and hopefully like I said
everything is set up correctly but we
won't know until I upload it as that
usually goes
Coulson has the white pieces and I
forgot to mention in tiebreaks this is a
blitz game so let's check it out cross
and opens with E 4 we have c5 the
Sicilian defense Knight to f3 d6 and now
Carlsen doesn't proceed with the usual
d4 but rather he goes for g3 preparing
to fianchetto his light square bishop
Khurana does the same he wants to be in
Cairo his light square bishop as well
we have Bishop to g2 Bishop to d7
attacking the e4 pawn and now comes
Queen to e2
defending the pawn we have d6 d4
C capture Sundy for a nightcap force on
d4 as it you know if it's a Sicilian
Knight to f6
and now comes castles by crossing now we
have Knight B to d7 and now as the d6
pawn is someone we cross and attacks at
rook to d1 and here you can just
continue development good black if you
continue with something like Bishop to
e7 you're gonna face a five opening up a
discovered attack from your from the
light square Bishop to this dark square
Bishop here sorry about that I have no
idea why that happened
let me just check that but yeah okay
this is one of the things that we'll
have to keep in mind let me just fix
that seems to be something up with the
interface yep sorry about that I noticed
how angry over when the last time my
interface faced problems but okay well
like we said opening up a discovered
attack from the bishop to the bishop on
b7 and also the knight on f6 is under
attack so you do have to do something
about this if you capture on g2 then
what we'll simply capture on f6 and now
two of your pieces are under attack the
bishop on g2 and also the Bishop on e7
so not something you want to do on the
other hand if you simply play D captures
on e5 you get Knight captures on e6 and
now after pawn captures you will only
now recapture on b7 but then Ruby eight
bishop goes back and with the two weak
points white will be much better if if
you know in in the hands of a strong
player this will be winning for white in
the long run but okay
like we said after rook to d1 Fabi first
goes for a six taking away the b5 square
from the knight but Carson goes be five
nonetheless now and okay what's the idea
here why did why did Cora wanna allow a5
Bishop captures and g2 we have phone
captures on f6 and okay now it's a
different story now you can move the
Bishop from from g2
but there is no Bishop on e7 to attack
but okay after Bishop to h3
here the bishop is no longer under
attack and here if Carlsen continues
with something like font captures here
button captures the bishop would already
be attacking then
here black could perhaps wiggle out of
this one but here after Bishop to h3 it
would seem Khurana missed a very nice
move by Carlsen so feel free to pause
the video here and find this very nice
idea that Indian the Carlsen used to win
this Bilbao masters 2012 edition so I
will give it a couple of seconds as
usual for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations
you are an excellent Punisher of weird
blitz ideas and for those who just want
to enjoy the show the move Carlsen plate
is Queen to h5 and Queen to h5 comes
with the terrible threat of Queen
captures Bishop and also it pins the f7
pawn making Knight captures on e6 a
pretty big threat but I mean Knight
captures an e6 is a threat but there's
really no square for Euro light square
bishop to go to if you try something
like Bishop to a5 it doesn't really make
sense
tonight captures pawn captures Queen to
e2 will win you the game either you will
have to block and lose the pieces this
way or Knight blocks and then f4 will
win the window Knight and eventually the
game but after this Queen to h5 move
quran decided not to do this he decided
to bling Queen captures on f6 and here
we have the simple Queen captures on h3
so here Carlsen ism up a piece but still
it's a blitz game perhaps anything can
still happen
we have Bishop to e7 Knight to c3 Queen
to g6 and here Knight to c6 not allowing
black the castle attacking the bishop on
e7 here corona plays nicely v attacking
the knight on c6 cousin simply captures
it King captures and now bush up to f4
and here corona resigned the game as it
was in this position that Cara wanna
resigned the game as there is really
nothing to do here
he's down a full Bishop and there are no
tricks in the position for example white
after black plays and white will simply
attack the rook for example rook can
move taking away the b7 square you can
capture tonight and then get your queen
to c6 and already you can see that the
black has no counter play here
whatsoever you can play something a ruby
dat captures captures
and then white will still be up a full
piece with no no counter plate for black
whatsoever so that's basically the game
and one of the tiebreak games that one
calls in this Bilbao masters 2012
edition so that's it for this game I do
hope you enjoyed it and that I haven't
blundered anything with this new setup
hopefully everything is working
correctly the sound the interface the
video the the I'm pretty sure a lot of
things can go wrong so better just to
test it and also since it's a very short
video I will share a story with you that
happened to me today when I landed in
Heathrow Terminal 5 there was this
gentleman I really I mean I didn't plan
this trip it was like a
spur-of-the-moment thing because I had a
lot of things that well this trip
depended on a lot of things and then
when all of the things went well I
decided to take the trip but I didn't
book any hotels or anything so when I
landed in London there was this it was
like guide for there was this gentleman
it was like for people who have no idea
what they're doing there was this booth
where you could ask for information and
I talked to this gentleman there and
while he was asking me do I want to book
a hotel how will I get there do I know
how to get around and he was really
really helpful you know it was it's very
rare to come up to to such a helpful
person but the most interesting part was
when he asked me why did I come to
London you know was the business or
pleasure I said like well it's hard to
say you know pretty much both but then
he asked me like why did you come here I
told him I'm here to visit the World
Chess Championship it's taking place
tomorrow in all born and he says that's
very interesting but you're like you're
the second person that already said that
I was like and who's the first person
and he said that he was that the
gentleman that said that before me was
very good-looking and
he had like floppy or curly hair or
something like that and that he said
that he was a chat chess champion he
also mentioned that he had a really
really peculiar name and then he
remembered that he said that it was
Magnus and then I asked was it Magnus
Carlsen and he replied I'm not sure
about the surname but I think it was and
then when he gould googled it on his
computer and saw his photo he said oh
yeah that was the gentleman that said
that he was coming here for the World
Chess Championship before you so that's
pretty interesting but it wasn't like we
missed each other I think he actually
arrived arrived yesterday so but still a
pretty cool story I mean you know glad I
came here so hopefully everything works
the sound is OK the videos okay if
everything is okay tomorrow I'll
probably throw in another warm-up video
tomorrow morning as I didn't do any
yesterday but hopefully everything will
work out nicely so that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it hopefully I didn't
blunder anything I would like to thank
Alessio pataka mr. Gavin Wales Ian
makini Alan Vishnevsky and Millard
bashira Tzadik for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot too really
appreciate it as usual you can check too
on my previous video series think'll for
watching and I will see you soon
most likely with another warm-up video
and then with Game one of the 2018 World
Chess Championship between Magnus
Carlsen and Fabiano Caruana thank you
all and I'll see you soon